we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p and here is
one voicemail i received that i have
some thoughts on yeah Trump explained
about the wall uh months ago by not
having the wall billions of dollars flow
south across the border every year yeah
although come a little money we put the
wall up and it will pay for itself many
times over in just the first year and
the billions of dollars flowing south to
Mexico will no longer flow south to
Mexico so in that respect Mexico is pay
for the wall because they're not getting
our money anymore yeah okay not this is
uh completely debunked I mean what money
drug money the money from people working
in the US who are here and then sending
money to their families in Mexico is
often time what what people mean we've
debunked all of this this stuff okay I
mean it number one first of all in terms
of the crime stuff uh undocumented
immigrants are actually less likely to
commit crime than people in the US
legally because they know that if
depending on what state they commit a
crime in if they're caught they'll be
deported so number one it's been totally
debunk that undocumented immigrants are
more likely to commit crime than any
other population that's here on a legal
basis number two immigrants even
undocumented immigrants are a
net-positive to the American economy
particularly because many of them are
paying into social programs that they
will never actually pull benefits out of
because they are here undocumented now
this isn't me saying break the law do
whatever you want anarchy but let's have
a discussion based in fact Louis where
we've debunked most of these talking
points about the undocumented immigrant
community yeah and let's debunk the idea
that this wall will ever happen not yet
Donald Trump becomes president is just
not gonna happen now there's not not
going to be a wall it's uh you you could
probably build fencing in some areas by
by executive action got this bigger wall
that he's talking about it is not going
to happen on the bonus show today we
will
talk about the Philippines drug killings
continuing we will also talk about an
NBA player that beat both Michael Phelps
and Ryan Lochte in swimming back in the
day and also a Texas lawmaker is now
targeting gun-free businesses we will
hear about all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show there is one way
to get access to the bonus show and it's
by being a david pakman show member and
of course you can sign up on the brand
new and very well reviewed by our
audience website david pakman.com slash
membership